welcome to the free pilot training
channel where today we're going to be
explaining
latitude and longitude just sit back and
relax
because we're going to do some studying
for that private pilot written exam
pilots need to be able to identify their
position on the globe
and one way we can do that is by using
latitude and longitude
just as you may remember from your high
school geography class
lines of latitude and longitude are
imaginary lines
drawn on a globe so we can help identify
our position
lines of latitude run laterally across
the globe and start with the equator at
zero degrees
and the equator divides our globe into
two equal segments the northern
hemisphere and the southern hemisphere
from the equator these lines run north
until they reach the top of the earth at
90 degrees north
these lines also run south until they
hit the bottom of the globe
at 90 degrees south one important thing
for you to remember
is that lines of latitude are parallel
with the equator
lines of longitude which are the red
ones you see here run perpendicular to
the equator
these start on the prime meridian which
runs through greenwich england
at 0 degrees then they end at 180
degrees which is roughly on the
international date line
when you travel west from the prime
meridian not only are you in the western
hemisphere
but you can see that these lines of
longitude actually bear a westerly label
and of course the opposite is also true
if you travel east of the prime meridian
now between every degree of latitude and
longitude
we break these up into minutes and there
are 60 minutes in between every degree
of latitude and longitude
and every one of these minutes equals
one nautical mile
that's why we use nautical miles instead
of statute miles in a lot of aviation
calculations
these minutes of latitude and longitude
or
increments of one nautical mile can be
further divided into
seconds and just like time there are 60
seconds
in one minute of latitude and longitude
and because minutes and seconds are in
increments of 60
most aviation calculations follow the 60
to 1 rule
incidentally that's how the old wiz will
flight computers work
if you're like me when you first saw how
one of these work you probably thought
it fell out of a flying saucer
anyways before we get too distracted
let's take a look at how we write out
these latitudes and longitudes
we also call these coordinates first
this n lets us know that we're in the
northern hemisphere
then this 32 lets us know that we're 32
degrees north of the equator
now if you remember from earlier every
degree has 60 minutes in it
and every minute equals one nautical
mile so we can take this number and
multiply it times 60 to get our distance
from the equator
so at 32 degrees north or 1920 nautical
miles from the equator but not so fast
we've still got some numbers left over
this next set of numbers indicates our
minutes so we can just add this
to our total distance from the equator
and this gives us a total distance of
1962 nautical miles
now this last line indicates our seconds
we've got 12 seconds here
that means 12 60 of a nautical mile
and if you do the math that's 0.2
nautical miles
that means we're exactly 1 900
nautical miles north of the equator now
the longitudes those work the same way
let's calculate this one real quick
first we're in the western hemisphere
then you can see that we're 91 degrees
west of the prime meridian
so if we multiply 91 times 60 you can
see
that we're 5460 nautical miles west of
the prime meridian
now let's go ahead and add our minutes
here remember
one minute equals one nautical mile so
let's go ahead and add 21 nautical miles
to get 5481 nautical miles
west of the prime meridian now let's
attack these seconds
we've got 15 seconds that means 15 60th
of a nautical mile
and this translates to 0.25 so let's
just add this to our total to get
5481.25 nautical miles
now you can start to see how we can use
these latitudes and longitudes
to give someone our exact position on
the globe
next let's pull out a vfr sectional and
i'll show you how the faa is going to
ask these questions on your written exam
the first question you might see on the
test is something like this
what are the coordinates for libby
airport well as you can see it's right
here but what are the coordinates
now right away you probably already
picked out the lines of latitude and the
lines of longitude
and as you can see they're pretty
obviously labeled here
but what makes this confusing is that
some of these lines of latitude and
longitude
don't have labels so you might not be
sure what the scale is
on vfr sectionals these unmarked lines
of latitude and longitude are actually
our 30-minute markers
this means that every other lat long
marking that you see indicates one
degree of change
now if we zoom in even closer you can
see that even the individual minutes are
marked on these vfr sectionals
don't forget these are one nautical mile
then this bigger hash mark
indicates 10 minutes once we know this
let's look at the question again
what are the coordinates for libby
airport first of all it's pretty obvious
that we're in the northern hemisphere so
let's put an
n here second libby is north of the 48th
parallel so let's put a 48 here
to figure out how much we might have to
zoom in a little bit
all we have to do is count these tick
marks i'm getting about 17
so let's add 17 minutes to our latitude
correct me if i'm wrong but it looks to
be dead on that mark so i'm not going to
add any seconds here
and the answers on the test shouldn't
only differentiate by seconds anyways
now that we've found our latitude let's
find our longitude
we know we're in the western hemisphere
because these numbers count up as we
travel west and now if you notice here
this longitude just prior to libby is
115 degrees
so now let's get our minutes you know to
me
it looks like this is one minute shy of
the 30 minute marker
so let's call this 29 minutes and that's
all we have to do to come up with
coordinates for a specific location
let's look at one more way they may ask
you this question
what is in the following location
well right away when i look at these
coordinates i know it's beneath the 47th
parallel here
and that's because these coordinates are
showing north of the 46th parallel
in fact it looks like we're only 2
minutes and 36 seconds short of the 47th
parallel
now right away when i'm drawing my line
on this map i'm wondering if it's one of
these two airports right here
it could even be this town of lincoln
our longitude is showing 112 degrees
and 44 minutes so we know we're east of
this mark here's 112 and 30 minutes
here's 112 and 40 minutes then this one
is 112
and 44 minutes now we'll take a quick
look at our seconds here
we've got 45 seconds which means 45 60
of a nautical mile and that's 0.75
nautical miles
so now that we've triangulated our
position it looks to me like cane ranch
airport is the answer to this question
hey i hope you learned something today
if you did please hit that like button
for me before you go see what other
videos i have available and don't forget
to subscribe if you haven't already
you'll thank yourself when you go to
take your written or your check ride
i'll see you next time
you